get all the coughs out left cold let's
go let's go
how you doing say yeah I'm good how you
doing yeah you look better my brother
gave me some sudafed on Saturday and my
whole head cleared up cleared up fired
up for you didn't make you drowsy
anything okay yeah so you needed a
little help yeah yeah I've been feeling
good yeah good I'll tell you what really
made me feel good
Eagles the Eagles beat the Rams a
double-whammy I didn't like it at all
and I lost 14 came through did cuz you
lost that one and the Chiefs I mean come
on don't listen everybody just listen to
me break down games I'm done telling
people who to pick see I wasn't even
thinking about your money yeah I by the
way guys I hope you guys had a great
weekend a lot of crazy stuff you have
watched the the Cowboys Colts game you
know just from watching the game yeah
you've already checked out the film of
Pat Steelers yes I had to dive into that
right and you went into the film of
Eagles Rams yeah we got that too yeah to
explain how did these things happen and
really didn't get him out can I have
this back now or no yes I just didn't
get through everything all right um we
are gonna be joined by cam Hayward
momentarily so Daryl you have to keep
listening to the podcast or watching the
podcast because I don't know we were
getting this guy today Josh was like hey
and josh is sick today cuz I think he
was infected he may have taken a sip of
that hot chocolate no I was in it and
you guys spooning so much it's an issue
true well you know I need someone that's
capable of being a big so but he was
like I think we can get Kim Hayward I
was like Kim Hayward I know well they
play the Patriots so no matter what
happens I'm gonna want to talk to cam
hey whatever he comes in he's coming to
us via Dick's Sporting Goods
let me while we wait because I kind of
want to in court incorporate him into
our Steelers Patriots talk this Eagles
came I need to explain to you that I had
emotionally moved on from this year yes
I had processed what has happened I went
it was the typical Superbowl year
hangover and we're moving on Carson
Wentz it I said last thing I need
Foles coming in here and making this a
controversy yeah this is the equivalent
to me as an Eagles fan right I have just
been in a relationship and I have been
broken up for six months and I'm feeling
pretty good about I'm finally coming
around and my ex calls me yeah
and she goes Adam remember that box of
all those great things that you thought
you lost I found it
come over let's have dinner for two two
weeks and afterwards I'm gonna give you
the box right and I'm sitting here and
I'm going man that box is pretty great
I just I remembered that box last year
the box is amazing yeah but I don't
think she got this box I think that
she's gonna invite me over for two weeks
and then just kind of like have me
expecting things and guess what no box
all right that's what it feels like
right now yeah and I don't want to get
emotionally invested yeah I wanted this
season to die yeah and now they go in LA
and Nick Foles suddenly activates a Sean
Jeffrey in a way that I have not seen
him since the Super Bowl right and the
offense the Wendel Smallwood ran over a
guy
and scored a touchdown so first thing
you know what I want to say about that
wherever the Eagles running last night
right up them right up the middle I mean
as you said this last year all of the
team when Carson went down said we to
play to full capability to make up for
the fact that Carson's not there which
infuriates me and excites me at the same
time and fury aids me why is this so
what you saw you last night and after
looking at the film yeah completely
different team yeah I mean if they
played this way the whole year with this
formula in which they wanted to attack
they wouldn't be in the position they're
in do they like Nick Foles more than
Carson Wentz well no and I'm gonna but
this is a great conversation first of
all I feel like this is like you broke
up with your girlfriend right and she
had all these flaws and you broke up
with her and then you called him up six
months later they're off and you're like
damn she's back to the perfect person I
thought she was what the hell that's so
messed up I mean that's where the what
has happened
yeah and I've seen this happen in my
experience in the NFL this
they drive me crazy moment that goes on
Oh our star players down coaches gonna
design plays that we haven't designed
all year all of a sudden they're gonna
come up plenty and then and the efforts
could be layers are being told we don't
have him if we don't win this area we
can't win this war Vaughn LeBlanc
yeah played out of his right cruffin
LeBlanc yeah you know the only time that
you should be named Craven LeBlanc if
you're sitting the French Revolution I
was gonna say if your dad owns a Swiss
chocolate company this is my son groove
on LeBlanc oh wow what a spoiled prick
right but I can't do they like Nick
Foles more well they because boy do they
get more pumped to play for Nick Foles
no III think it's first of all we've
talked about this all year that this is
the missing aspect I think the biggest
thing is this and coaches fall into this
trap say oh you mean like the
straight-ahead running yes and just the
fact that they don't run the ball as
well as they did last year people don't
you know gotta realize last year was the
third best running team in football this
year it's the 29th best team I saw Aaron
Donnell getting tossed lost and they're
double-teaming them and moving them
instead of going sideline to sideline
cuz he's gonna win that race against
Brendan Brooks okay
but I think this is what happens a lot
of times in these cases too you have a
star awesome quarterback right like
Carson Wentz and he's every day
impressive and I think it enamors the
coaches players they see it in practice
and they go now let's just put him back
there in the shotgun and he'll dice
people up and he does to a degree but
you can't create any big plays off of
him because he became one-dimensional
they know foals is not capable of kind
of doing that and dicing people up Falls
was solid lesson he wasn't like he was
great I mean I could show you another
look at SAC hurts every play no he did
not
I get that he also missed Zach Ertz in
almost an interception to Zach Ertz who
was wide open Sims in my group chat
still I have people saying do we trade
winds yeah oh I mean go head see how
that works but if the Eagles go on a run
yeah and win a Super Bowl
right with Nick Foles oh then maybe I'll
change my tune if they do that again
yeah maybe their own fault you trade
Carson Wentz David a David it might have
to think about it yeah I mean they
really
there's no joke I mean I mean Nick Foles
can't like scratch the surface on Carson
Wentz's they're just his talent again
I'm gonna say this one more time Nick
Foles is really good this is a very good
matchup with things that the Eagles did
the Eagles adjusted the way they played
a little bit on both sides of the
football and it all kind of just fell
into place for Nick Falls and it's just
unfortunate that it took the carson
wentz injury to kind of get your offense
of mindset back to know we're gonna have
to run the ball we're gonna have to
dominate the line of scrimmage a little
bit that's so funny yeah I'm looking
your notes now for the first yeah why
did it have to take when's getting hurt
for the Eagles to play like this it's
not foals people are open yeah so you're
seeing different place
dad we haven't seen you yeah I mean the
play they ran to Al Sean Geoffrey down
in the middle the jump ball that was him
and Senegal or what oh yeah right
like like the Rams were going for
another play I mean from would buy with
I think joiner and Aqib Talib were like
oh they're in this formation we know
what they're running and they ran out
for somebody to run to the corner and
nobody ran to the corner yes so there
was a few different place but the big
thing is they got underneath Center they
ran play-action pass the big thing is
for every Eagles man out there who
watched the game last night you
explained it all the big runs were
designed to run in the middle and which
is against endemic and soon a Darren
Donald yes you know they ran the trap
like the first Sproles run you saw the
game that Donald get ahead him go up
right you let him fly upfield somebody
just kind of hits him in the hip and
he's gone and see you later and that's
right up the middle you know they're
they're a little undisciplined like that
they're very aggressive and the in the
middle run game some nice pass designs
and good throws by foals I'm not trying
to take anything away we're all good and
then the defense played smart I mean you
know what is my always my other issue
but the Eagles why are we playing bump
with mouths beavers Cooper why we
Blitzen on third and 14 so they can
throw the jump ball to get 15 yards yeah
none of that crap happened last none of
it Wow and let's get back to the
we have a special guest is he here yes
cam Hayward honestly one of the most
favorite defensive lime in the NFL for
us the last few years yeah the fact that
he's only been to one Pro Bowl is a sham
yeah
statistics are nonsense this guy
destroys every offensive lineman you put
on the film every week right cam
welcome to the show okay uh uh how you
guys doing thank you for having me no of
course we're having you man we're good I
mean we're we're pumped I mean I root we
root for you guys first of all I think
left comb and I have a man crush on your
defense I know I certainly do yeah
just because of you step on to it you
know Hargrave you guys are so
unbelievable yeah outside TJ you got
beefs I don't know if you remember
seeing me a training camp not this past
year but two years ago I'm Chris Sims by
the way just but you know I'm
rootaberger thanks man yeah I root for
Mike T all right so I was glad to see
you guys get the victory against the
Patriots last night all we're saying is
we're very happy for you dude how good
it had to feel great yeah it was a great
win especially after our three-game
losing streak you know to get another
call another one in the win column you
know goes a long way but it was first a
really good team you know you have to be
accountable for all things and you know
it's a game that comes down to a couple
plays and we were able to make those
this past game let me just say really
quick Hayward joins us on the phone now
he's supporting a hometown company
Dick's Sporting Goods sports matter
initiative which helps to fund
underserved youth sports programs across
the country by providing resources out
with fields equipment league fees etc
you can learn more about cams work worth
at sports Matt org and apparently you
were rockin some dope cleats so let me
hear about that for you back to the game
yeah well good reached out and you know
I do a lot of work with kids in general
underprivileged kids in general and you
know what better way to help
underprivileged kids and to provide
sports Dick's Sporting Goods you know
provides all different types of sports
for so many different kids and you know
there
just trying to raise money because
building as you said billions are being
cut for after-school programs whether
it's basketball football baseball soccer
tennis track you name it but we're
working together and I got to wear some
pretty cool
cleats I think we get to keep wearing
them for the next couple of weeks but
I've to check on that but uh
you know it's just a great organization
to be part of and you know we're doing
the right thing by doing this yeah
definitely are all right so I mean let's
talk about the game yesterday yeah
what'd you see I did I just watched the
film of your football game so I would
like to just hear you know to me it
looked like I when Brady was first and
second down you guys are gonna put
people at the line of scrimmage maybe
blitz a little in those situations but
whenever it was a passing situation it
was three or four men rushed the whole
game like you guys said we're not gonna
give Brady any one-on-one chances but I
would like to just hear kind of what
your overall philosophy was yesterday
playing against the Patriots and tell us
what it's like to play against Tom Brady
because he's pretty good yeah well first
play against Tom Brady you know you got
to be on all your P's and Q's everybody
has to be accountable you know as a DB
you got to be aware that he could go to
your guy because he features so many
different guys and you know he's gonna
keep bouncing back and you know they're
waiting for that play to put them over
the top and throughout the game we just
thought to ourselves we got a win with
three and four man pressure you know
we're gonna blitz a little bit but our
four-man rush has to be high I know we
didn't get as many sacks I think TJ got
the only sad but you just rested him a
lot right getting pressure up to his
face right um you know and sometimes you
just want those balls to fail we got the
pressure on the Joe Haden pick which was
critical for us and you know we were
just you know we were flying around you
know getting them off this point you
know multiple tacklers you think I love
was everything with a competitive ball
except one ball that was a touchdown
right no with Greg and with with with
Brady you just have to have everybody
accountable accounted
or because if they're not and they're
not making a competitive catches all the
time he's gonna he's gonna beat you
yeah I don't know what Artie Burns was
doing in that play but I know it was his
fault because he never came back in the
game after that so all out him right
here and you don't have to say anything
don't say I don't know we were gonna
play a lot of corners
I think our safety guys a little bit
confused because they went so deep with
the route and then came back but I I
don't think it was already small I think
you know we switched a little bit and I
got everybody confused but uh yeah we're
gonna need already throughout the game
throughout the year he's just gonna be
ready from four other moments good good
answer leader of the defense that was
very well done very proud of you right
there hey really quick can you just say
you're my first my last my everything
really quick you're my first you're my
last you're my everything man you got
that Barry White voice right now yes
Massimo that's why I think when you when
you get back tonight you should go hey
baby
well we actually have like our annual
d-line dinner tonight so oh we take we
take our significant other so we having
a good time tonight where does the
Pittsburgh D line go for their Big D
line dinner where do you where is it in
the steakhouse it's always the
steakhouse we we choose a different one
every year
tomorrow so no one's gonna know right so
like it's funny because like we had
already had a plan after the New England
game and we thought you know either
we're gonna drink and have a good time
or we're gonna drink and have a good
time so I have just a season career
question for you in every sport when an
athlete performs really well they get
rewarded by being on an all-star team
the NFL is crazy to me because everyone
will say the most important positions
are the trenches the line of scrimmage
and an offensive lineman or a defensive
lineman like yourself can dominate the
whole year and not get the certain
statistics in which
public even realizes that and I'm just
curious if that's frustrating oh you
know it does get frustrating at times
because you know you want to be
recognized for the work you're doing
your teammates let you know right it's
like all internal it's like the coach
puts your film and it's like cam
destroyed this team this week and you're
like and nobody has any idea right you
know but you know in the greater glory
of it when you win a Super Bowl it
doesn't just say one guy want it you
know it says every every single guy on
that team on it and those are the goals
we look forward to you know the
recognition is nice and everybody wants
to get recognized for doing their jobs
but you know you got to have bigger
goals you know we got to keep you know
we have to stay hungry you know I think
if we get too wrapped up in the
individual and thinking that we don't
get recognized then we don't we don't
get to accomplish our finger goals yeah
I mean okay all right two questions I
want to add the first time they grow
well your psyche like what's your psyche
like okay going into oh gosh we got the
New England Patriots coming into town
right they've kind of owned us for the
last you know twelve years no disrespect
to you or your teammates he's only been
there yeah right and then you come off
of three losses Broncos Chargers and
Raiders where I've said here and left go
and I have done this pocket says they've
been the better team ever you guys have
dominated all three games like what was
the locker room like leading up to this
game in this week you pissed her you mad
yes yeah everybody was pretty pissed you
know you you know you could feel like
the the pettiness of the team's is where
everybody's just a little bit on edge
right I throw out every practice and um
you know but it didn't take away from
our from the way we practice and it
didn't take away from the way we were
going to attack the weak and that's why
I really came from that we could be
pissed off of what we've done and we
could be annoyed with what we put on the
field and having finished games but the
quickest way to get over a loss is a win
on Sunday
and you know that's what we're gonna
have to continue to do you know we've
made our bed and we have delayed it but
uh you know the outcome is not written
we have to continue to work we have to
continue to prepare and be ready for
these good things to play throughout ma
I want to ask one follow-up to that as
we talk about Tomlin all the time yeah I
believe that that no team comes back
better when they're angry than a Mike
Tomlin team and I was just curious like
how did how did you like what did you
watch him do to try and channel your
guys and energy to that week he just
asked everybody to be very hard on
yourself as you grade yourself right
after again you know obviously came back
from Oakland it was a late night but as
soon as we got back to work it was why
are why are we not you know winning
these games what's it coming down to and
it wasn't necessarily a building thing
but then he would go around individually
and challenge other other people and say
this is where you fell short this one
easier this week um you know and I think
understanding that you know you got to
be hard on yourselves on what you did
but we got to make the adjustments now
and get right back to the game we were
able to do that for real how I like this
comes up a lot when we talk to you
people don't realize that your father
was Ironhead Hayward I don't know we're
a big dad boy and I just yeah of course
my dad played against your father when
he was with the Saints and everything
and I grew up here in Jersey hearing
about your dad at Passaic high school
all the time so was there ever any
running back in your life at what point
did you outgrow running back and say
okay I can't do that I got to put a hand
on the ground well it was funny I think
there was a time in like freshman or
high school I was playing deep into line
but then the coach came up to me because
they they had some injuries that Ronnie
backers like to play run it back for us
and I was all set to play running back
right before the game but then my dad
nixed it it was just like hey you were
you
way too tall to be playing running back
I was already taller than my dad so for
me to be playing running back would not
have been a good idea I was just gonna
get chopped down the entire time your
your mom your mom's tall like that was
actually what I was in the ass next
because I I've seen you I remember
seeing your dad in person and
remembering that he wasn't real tall or
not like you so your mom must have some
height with her or is there more height
on the dad's side of the family that I
don't know about oh well everybody my
dad's side are just short and stubby
right like the way right but then on my
mom's side she's five nine five and then
her dad was six six so yes I got it most
former side she likes to say I got my
athletic side from her as well Eames do
you know why is he really good she's
like a dennis rodman type of player so
oh I don't have too much Simms do you
know why his name was Ironhead I have a
story here on Wikipedia I don't know if
it's mmm man I don't know but I'm gonna
guess because he just would put his head
down and nobody wanted to get in the way
part of it cam is this pool cue story
true it is all right so you tell they
told me yeah my mom told me years back
that uh Cal Cal hold on one second
I'm sorry that was my son just walked in
don't worry they were at a Boys and
Girls Club and they he was talking and
crap as usual and he ended up giving the
pool cue snapped over his head
and he came home and his mom caught him
iron head and the legend lives on yeah
so some dude came up smashed a pool cue
over his head and his mom goes you're an
iron really he wore an 8 and 3/4 hat Wow
your size is on my side size head I like
it
all right so you got the Saints this
week so there's no rest for the weary
how do you how do you keep that energy
going we want to see you going to run
sims picked you guys to win the Super
Bowl before the year yeah you know I
think what we have to do is realize
we're playing another good team we have
to be ready for
you know a really good offense that's
balanced and both run in the past and
just prepare butts off don't take
anything for granted but understand that
uh you know we got to go out there win
it no one's gonna give it to us yeah no
doubt awesome cam you're the man dude
really appreciate it and if again if you
want to check in and see what he's doing
make sure that you go to sports matter
dot org cam congratulations good luck we
appreciate your time buddy appreciate
you guys thanks for having me
good man kick ass and vote for the pro
ball in the all pro give it to us thank
you guys say Jesse about man he's a
beast he's a beast my G sweet just I
only have like my life usually happens
on a Monday though for me but you know
what I respect just lousy I'll let you
figured I'd enough to know it's just you
know you know how we talk about like you
know teams who put a lot of pressure on
their great corners right you know like
New England for instance they put a lot
of pressure on Stephon Gilmore and JC
Jackson and I'll talk about in a minute
Pittsburgh is like the same way except
with their D tackles I mean they they
basically do it in Hayward you're play
all game you do 70 snap right get after
the quarterback stop the run do every
used to say this about Minnesota
normally does Pittsburgh get tired by
the end of the year no Pittsburgh has
better depth than years past it started
to get better last year and what they
have now with Hargrave in their JD
Walton red colors they got Chikara real
low don't dakari yeah who if you
remember out of Tennessee there's like
six eight 350 and people were like I
just don't know what he can do right and
the Steelers went he can give us 10 to
15 snap right yep all right um let's
just go back to Ramsey Eagles really
quick ok the other thing about the I
wanna just stop for a minute and read
them over and then we'll start up again
you know I'm really good at doing on the
flood ok I've already read it alright
fine which side that we were on the
Eagles offensive side we were right
the other thing that you wrote in your
notes about the Rams defense was they're
afraid of lead of putting their corners
on an island yeah so how long has this
been the issue well you know again I
didn't judge it too hard you know what
was my issue with them if like a week
ago two weeks ago I said they did do too
much on defense times right I have no
problem with them being simple and
they've actually been simple the last
two okay
but within being simple doesn't mean you
got to be soft like they're there it's
off soft zone the whole game and at some
point on third and threes and third and
fours he weren't jamming and they gotta
get like I'm gonna say three plays I'll
tell you I thought there's no one the
Eagles that just scared that I that's
that's was one of the shocking things of
the game to me it really was and and
what's weird is like one of the first
third downs of the game they've jammed
and hurts be to keep to leave on a
little fade yes and I feel like they
became gun-shy from that point on but at
some point you know I always look at a
team right and you and I and we both do
this together where's the money on your
team and is it performing damn there's a
lot of money in that Ram secondary and
there are a lot of good players and it's
some pressure on they got it they're
gonna have to take some of the pressure
for games like this when their offense
isn't great it's kind of an ugly game
there and they need some extra help
stopping the run or maybe getting
pressure at the quarterback yes because
they could have they needed to blitz a
few times last night or do something to
change the pace of the game and they
didn't do that and they're very
reluctant to put Peters and to leave in
those situations I'm gonna wrap up my
Eagles point with this yeah do I think
they could beat the Texans at home I do
the Texans are a pretty rough away team
do I think they could beat Washington
yes do I think that Minnesota and
Carolina could lose a game the rest of
the year you bet your ass
especially with Minnesota playing
Chicago yeah do I think Dallas could
lose two games home against Tampa Bay at
the Giants yeah maybe not but it could
happen too right I'm not gonna talk in
this whole playoff percentage 32%
whatever if it happens great and this
whole carson wentz coming back and
playing in my mind we've entered it's
either Nick Foles Magic Man or bust yeah
I don't want carson wentz back no no
it's got a
it's a fractured back situm put him on
IR get him out here there's what are you
gonna do Nick Foles is gonna glede you
the playoffs you put carson wentz in the
divisional game Bulls team right now
because of performance right you have
you fractured back yeah get away I get
you go hunting with your brother
I I'm with you no he wants to stay there
and be supportive you ain't that's rude
read read the Bible before the game geez
the other thing I was gonna say yes no
one's really questioning the Rams
defense allowing points they've been
doing that for a better part of the year
yeah the Rams offense is now the thing
that everyone is going what the hell and
even before I looked at your notes and I
had it written down as the number one
thing to ask you
the overrated nature and possibly Silent
Assassin the bye week yes right every
team every year looks at the bye week
like a vacation the Rams were not just
cruising they had an all time
performance against the Chiefs it is so
bad to have the bye week when you're
performing well when you're not then the
season goes in the direction I'm really
starting to believe that teams go the
opposite direction once they hit the bye
week you've been killing it you're gonna
bet and you tell the story about the ten
Innova Titans all the time yeah ten
notes I am the six and OH Broncos where
I was on six no bongos by week probably
didn't win a game I think we lost five
in a row after it I mean or maybe six we
might have gone six and no to six and
six it was something like that into him
he's and their bye week was after the
game of the year right right everybody
telling you how awesome and our golf was
better than Patrick Mahone right it's
Thanksgiving weekend so they probably
even had an extra like super phat
exactly super phat extra drinks even
extra day off that's a bye week whatever
it may be
offense was not good against the Lions
no comes back the next week scores what
3 points against the Bears right then
comes back the next week and really
didn't have it going all night I've
heard people saying that they go teams
are letting the Rams run right they're
going we're not gonna fall for any of
your play action if you want to do those
sweeps run it run it for 12 plays is
that what you saw in the film no it's
good yeah no it's it's there's the car
who is that well of course it is I mean
okay so there's so many things I want to
say here first of all before we even
dive into this I just want to make one
more statement about their defense as it
pertains to the offense because you
brought it I do connect because the
defense is built to be on a team that
has a ten and fourteen point lead
they're not made to be in these oh let's
go all right and they've somebody Chiefs
right they've played three games in a
row where the team has figured that out
and the common thing with all three
games too is that they play defenses
with good defensive tackles and that is
the issue there the reason they are
lying as well there's an eagle and even
if you go back to the Lions game and I'm
gonna pull it up because I'm pretty sure
Gurley ran for a hundred guards against
the Lions yeah but a lot of it it was
late yeah it was like two big runs like
yeah the game because I had the Rams as
a tenant up like a ten point favorite
great I was sweating it out the entire
game that's all I wanted to say because
that was a misleading stat line oh yeah
to me the issue is exactly the running
game and what I saw on film is that the
fact that they can't run the ball
consistently the last three weeks and
teams have realized there's issue in the
interior part of that offensive line
they have said okay yes we're not going
to commit a lot of people to the run but
because teams are calling their bluff is
what I'm saying they're going our front
four can stop your offensive line is
we're gonna give up everybody we're
gonna drop and and so there's romping
they're really challenging them to run
they are they're calling their bluff
this is it crazy you challenge your team
to run with Todd Gurley and it's I mean
this is what got them and what's the
killing this now is now that they're not
being able to run their offense as we
know and we've tried to tell people who
all have to play axe it's all off the
run game there than one of the best
running teams in football you wrote here
I can't always be inside zone yes so it
sounds like when you write that yeah
that the Rams can have a running game
but they can't rely on these guards to
do side to side no they got to change
some schemes in the run game
it cannot be when I tell you they run
the ball 20 times a game 18 of them are
inside zone right you simply explain an
inside zone is like all five working as
a unit kind of going in one area and
just blocking somebody you're in in your
area and why does that magnify their
guards well it magnifies their guards a
lot of the times because it's still
gonna be them man-to-man on a defensive
tackle and if they don't get a good get
off or something like that toss they get
tossed but it just makes a prediction if
you want double teams I want some double
teams they need to run some pulling
guards they need you want to pull those
guards that you don't like yeah they got
to do something together they're not
doing any good on what they're doing now
so they got to do something different
I'm just our golf has to get hurt Sean
Mannion comes in Sean McVeigh will
actually ski just good they just got to
change some looks up because I do think
they're very predictable off that and
when their run game doesn't work again
this is one of the best running teams in
football this is the number one play
action pass team in football right
and now the zones not working the
play-action passes and is good and now
because the runnings not working of
course the play-action passes and it's
good and because the running is not as
good the play-action screens are not as
good and then off of that would their
other run that they like to sprinkle in
and you've seen them do this left go
where he kind of turns like he's any
given inside zone and he flips it out
because they get on the edge because
we've been killing you with zone zone
zone and then he takes a false step and
they flip it on the outside and he gets
on the edge well that's not working
either because everyone's going well we
don't need to overly aggressively react
to the lack of your inside zone run game
right now and that's the issue but every
team has issues on their football team
and we have found out that the Rams
biggest issue is depth on their team is
in general they are they will they front
learn authority team right and it's week
15 yes when it starts to show it starts
to show I do wonder if they're worn out
a little bit and 65 66 in the middle are
issues for that football team and Sapp
folds nothing great either
I mean he's nothing great but 65 and 66
are an issue that I am concerned with
getting one number that has a 6 in it
also 16
I'm gonna read little clip it's of your
notes about mr. Jared Goff yeah he is
spoiled in that the first guy is usually
wide open yeah
such a bad throw it's continuous ramse
will now realize it all revolves around
girly goth bumble bumble stumble Higby
was open for huge gain golf can't make
off schedule plays miss to wide open
touchdowns this was a bad game and we
blamed last game on two things
yeah three things yeah you're playing
Chicago right you're playing in Chicago
they're right and it's really cold yeah
you're playing in LA it's warm against a
defense that dak Prescott shredded yeah
what what's going on I mean it's he's in
a funk there's no doubt about it and you
know the thing we praised about him
early hope you're set so he does he's
helpless right he's lost his confidence
in his mojo a little bit because he's
not exactly sure where the ball is going
to go outside of when it leaves his hand
right now he's let me just think about
the interception the zips not there the
zip is not there right the ball is doing
like these worldly turnovers as it spins
it's like a soft spiral and the accuracy
is not there as well I mean you know you
think about the interception that avanti
Maddox got sure that ball was dying out
I mean he had a dive on the ground to
get it that was a comeback route he
threw I'm gonna say 10 to 15 feet off
target inside I mean the guy he's open
if he throws it towards the sideline
leads him out to the side it's gonna be
a completion but he totally missed the
target you know think about at the end
of the half they kicked the field well
if you remember to go make it 13 right
yes
he had Gurley down the middle I mean
girl he's running this behind up through
it be I mean he's he's wide I mean it's
it's 2 plays before that he had a wheel
route to Gerald Everett wide touchdown
out of bounds misses him high at the
very end of the game yeah to see Sean
McVeigh's face yeah after some of the
Jared Goff passes yeah even I could tell
Sean was sitting there going
what's going on right now yeah he is
he's his mechanics are a little flawed
he's getting that frozen front shoulder
that I've talked about you and I have
talked about how his arm angle breaks a
little bit and I think between that and
nobody is immune to the fact that his
guards have moments of getting run over
and he's going he's his internal clock
has been screwed up the last three weeks
because he's had one clock for 13 weeks
and now he's had a Expedia's like damn
wait but I used to count to three before
I threw this ball right now I gotta
throw it at one-and-a-half or I'm
getting decked which is so crazy Sims
because what did everybody tell us when
he was drafted yeah
he's made to be off-balance yeah right
look at his year at Cal he had no good
offensive linemen he throws on the run
he's we were told explicitly that Jarrod
Golf is better scrambling around than
Carson Wentz and I don't think it's
close not no of course not it's
definitely not and this was always my
concern with golf and this is the thing
that you know hey I was very apology I
thought of all that I was very
apologetic towards and early in the year
because you saw him make plays off
schedule he had a different arm right
right now he is yes I mean he is not
making any place off schedule
oh he's hurting the team more than he's
helping them right now and yeah he's
just kind of fallen in love with in line
with the rest of their team where
they've all lost you know mechanics
they're dying out I don't know what it
is either way and they played three
teams that match up with them pretty
well too I have another theory yeah go
ahead a mirror remember we have the
Patriots theory that when you play the
Patriots what they Keyon on your offense
every team afterwards goes we'll take
that away too I mean it started with
Patricia yeah I know the Lions I know
and thinking back to did Patricia really
show the blueprint I do think to a
degree Patricia showed at the very least
a Shawn Robinson and next and snacks
over those guards can handle that by
themselves what were people doing before
that this never came to the forefront
you know I think that you know people
were just trying to let's sort of get
your guy in the box
let's they weren't trusting those
players
we're blitzing the edges yeah not
necessarily I just don't think the
issues there had been revealed yet
I think the Rams were kind of lucky that
they had not and I'd have to pull fish
to pull it up pull it up I'm pretty sure
they had played a schedule that did not
have the defensive tackles that they've
had a face well Chris Jones had a lot of
success Chris Jones had success he did
no doubt about it so there you go
Seahawks before that no special details
eighths before that yeah I mean Sheldon
had a few good plays in that game
Sheldon ranked as he did I don't know I
don't know if Wilkerson was available
for the Packers he got hurt I believe in
that game but they did have success
early on the Packers did yep they slowed
down the run Broncos well the real
question is cardinals next week Niners
the week after that are not gonna the
Rams should be fine yes they should be
but my other thing that I'm thinking is
the 49ers game will be dangerous that
would be dangerous you talking about
Kyle Shanahan's gonna have a chance to
screw up his buddy Shawn McVeigh and his
division rivals like maybe two seed and
the NFC playoffs they're 49ers you gonna
get off on that they're gonna they're
gonna be motivated to play this is cool
we can guy one more game here and it
means something and we can kind of ruin
it for them that's that's what division
teams are there for they're gonna bounce
back but I'm gonna say that when you
look at the conference standings right
now and you realize that the Rams are 11
and 3 and the Bears are 10 and 4 yeah
the Saints play Panthers dealers
Panthers yeah if the Saints lose to the
Panthers which I don't think is that
crazy and then lose to the Steelers if
the Saints somehow don't get one of
these buys and the Bears get to buy I'm
willing to say that I think the Bears
can go that not can I willing to say the
Bears are going to the Superbowl
yeah because I don't think the Saints or
the Rams
are going into Chicago in January and
win that game and I definitely don't
think Dallas or Seattle or Minnesota
will and then if the Bears have to go to
LA for the championship game there's
gonna be more Bears fans than Rams fans
by like 4 X 5 no our games not gonna
change anything to me bears going
the Rams is not going to change anything
other than that you would think off in
the offense would be a little more
comfortable after what you're telling me
but yeah Hicks may have 5/7 but yeah
they match up issues are not gonna go
away that they have there Billy Oh Greg
Williams oh they were just things that
I've let's talk about that right now
here Billy Oh Billy O'Brien Billy
O'Brien 13 11 13 minutes and 41 seconds
in the third quarter calls a timeout in
the game the other night
those are things where I wrote it down
because I wanted to see if it came back
to bite them in the ass you're saying it
was already second in 2011 but I'm
saying before that right but you're
going its third 11 who cares like you're
your conversion rate for third and 11s
probably in the 20s maybe high teens and
it's probably 1% better than third and
16 right so you're gonna waste the
second half time out on third and 11 on
I think it was like their own 29 and you
know what happened the next play got
sacked good thing they called that
timeout together why'd you write Greg
Williamstown Greg Williams he went full
tropic thunder okay we're at the end of
the game the other night it's 17 to 16
kick the [ __ ] field goals are you
kidding me
like don't tell me you're good then the
comment is we were going for the win so
then you kick the field goal cuz that's
what insured more of the win because to
miss the field goal and then give a
quarterback oh I only have to go 30
yards to kick the field goal to win it
right or you kick the field and go up by
four and now the quarter actually goes
75 yards the score touchdown that's the
play to win the game I'm so sick of this
aggressive Jason Garrett going for it
I'm so yeah but you know dog Peterson at
midfield last night I mean are you
kidding me the Rams are in struggles
ville fourth down and you're gonna do
Adelaide wrong
you're gonna give like right struggling
offense Rams a chance to revive
themselves Matt Nagy faking a punt the
Packers can't move a ball on you and me
on defense and you're up seven which
again
couple dates yeah and you're gonna fake
upon at midfield Oh guess what happened
yeah that's right it happened he scored
a touchdown yeah Roger why would you do
that
well aggressive I think what you're
saying is a very interesting point let's
look around the media yeah I'm not
hearing those coaches being questioned
all buddied anyone I know you know why
because when you go for it on fourth
down
you can blame execution you can blame
player performance our guard didn't
block you're right our running back
didn't get the edge so it's deflecting
on us because if you don't go for it
people can go is Jason Garrett too safe
is Billy O'Brien not getting the play
call in time
remember that delay of game Greg
Williams I don't know Cleveland needs a
spark is he the right spark but if you
go for it on fourth down you went for it
you did your job which is to play Madden
right go for it on fourth yeah that's a
great point because I'm not seeing any
think pieces about Jason Garrett today I
just don't understand it but if it you
know if he would have kicked the field
goal there yeah would have been shut out
no you shut out I mean you just don't
know they're there everybody's
undervaluing points and Melo tech takes
the field goal at all times pretty much
I mean when he gets in that situation we
saw what weren't they down 14 to 10 and
he kicked a field goal yeah well not
last night because they missed they
didn't kick it but no there was another
time way that we're missing though he
know it was 14 7 7 1 and he said exactly
right cuz he could see the game he knew
points we're gonna be at a premium and
that's my thing is like you can go oh
but look the Cowboys needed to score
points I don't know you gave the Colts
so much momentum yeah and it was like
bang bang - quick throws and now your
defense is dead
right they're dead yes kickoff reset
right feel happy about getting some
points right offense has a different
feel when they come out in the field and
they're going oh man they just scored
some bad aggressive some people it feels
desperate yeah and when it's desperate
and it doesn't work out you put yourself
in a worse hole yeah all right Pat
Patriots Steelers
I wanted to say that the first thing
that I noticed from your notes about the
Steelers defense was pride and you
express it there to cam Hayward they
only brought three or four they dropped
everybody back and you wrote that they
were actually able to make Tom really
uncomfortable they were with three or
four they were proud of I was proud of
him I really was I just you know um I
don't know I'm rooting for the Steelers
this year you said great job to disguise
the concept ray job you said that for
rushers got Brady uncomfortable a lot
Brady rushed decisions with three
rushers it's not like him not like even
that interception yeah what was going
online yeah I mean he just review point
he is he is um you know he did it in the
Dolphins game - he's deaf share what
you've seen the last two weeks on the
shuttle it's alright he's definitely
jumpy right now there's no doubt about
it there's been a number of times even
before the last two weeks where I've
gone on like old Brady would have sat
there and patted the ball and hit that
25-yard out route Brady right now is
just going oh the guys in the flats open
let me just throw it and get it out and
I go damn that's just that's not Brady
like so those are little things that to
me showing age maybe not wanting to get
hit a little bit he's he's worried about
that aspect of the game to a degree but
the Steelers would those beast they have
up up up front I mean they the pressure
was on them it was okay man we're gonna
rush three and four the whole game and
you guys got to get there and it doesn't
have to be sacks like cam Hayward said
you just got to make them feel
uncomfortable make them feel like people
are around him so he gets the ball of
his hand a hair quicker than where did
he say in my face
yes Brady is one of the best ever at
stepping up in the puck yes but when the
pockets coming into him have the Eagles
create pressure last year exactly right
Brandon Graham right in his face no
doubt you also wrote the Steelers
doubled Gronk and Edelman and wrote way
to go Steelers yes they did like New
England [ __ ] in this game on a few
obvious past situations they doubled
those two or which is crazy cuz I'm more
worried about Gordon well they doubled
him too he was a part of the run it was
just they it was always two on a play
there's two guys got double you can't
double three
right no but they took like if it was
third and four I felt like it was
Edelman and Gronk and I have to go back
to chart that it was a little longer
then Gordon got doubled with Grunk or
whatever it may be but or it could have
been Gronk and Gordon doubled and then
Joe Hayden man-to-man on Edelman today
much a patriot say they did a lot of
that stuff so between that and just a
few situations maybe four or five snaps
the whole game yeah and then like I've
said I don't know if there's a defense
right now in football that marries
coverages together more and when I say
marries them together it's like same
thing I say with offense where I go they
make the same play look different right
it's it's the same play when they says
set hut but Andy Reid Reina fake reverse
and a fake reverse the other way to make
you think it was something different but
at the end of the day it was the same
damn pie you prepared for all week and
that's what Pittsburgh's good at
Pittsburgh might make it look like three
deep and you go oh they're playing three
deep and then the middle safety it also
too becomes Tampa to the two down
safeties go back and play the deep
safety the middle safety now is playing
the linebacker position in Tampa too
like he's down in the middle and you
don't know until the ball is snapped
what exactly it is and those are little
advantages even though they look stupid
on film or on TV against a guy like Tom
Brady who's trying to look at the rush
he's talking to people who let a
scrimmage
okay I think this is it during this the
events let me check to this moody Bob if
I said huh say I got the ball let me see
oh wait there in that coverage holy [ __ ]
I they were in another coverage right
before I snapped it yeah and it's just
those little micro seconds that can give
your demons an advantage alarm clock
Steelers are so good I am like when they
wake up they're so good they match up
with anybody in the NFL there's still
one of the best teams in the league for
my money it's just whether they screw it
up or not
so we'll see last thing just to wrap up
that side of the ball you really did say
the Patriots were moving it well yeah
but it was mistakes and penalties never
seen anything like it
for the for the Patriots that messed it
up cannon with a huge penalty right
before the interception Hannon Trent
Brown had holding penalties they had
illegal formations you know James White
dropped a top throw on a third down at
one
it was just unpatriotic sin a row now
you know again added to the fact that
Brady goes backwards in the pocket and
throws a ball up for interception down
in the red zone I mean those things just
don't happen to New England at the same
time yeah so many Patriot things kept
them in the game yeah right the punt
downed at the 1 yeah right grow up
Belichick perfectly managing the clock
at the end of the half so that Ben
doesn't even touch it right I'm noticing
a trend in the NFL yeah of purposely
taking false start penalties to keep the
clock there's a loophole Indiana
noticing it definitely yes because I
believe that the Patriots tackle
purposely false star he did and the
clock kept running I did there's it they
found a loophole and it happened in a
game two weeks ago - and I can't
remember because I'm pretty sure I wrote
the notes it might have been but it was
it was the Bears it was the Bears Rams
Sunday night last week
McVeigh did it was it McVeigh Ord Negi
I'm pretty sure it worth it happened in
the game though you're exactly right
yeah it was like a minute and four left
in the first half they jumped offsides
under the clocks are you cheatin extra
25 seconds they have found a loophole
the NFL needs to fix it because and then
Romo is just waxing poetic oh look at
him look at this shift and then Nance is
like of all the touchdowns you get
excited about clock management but
that's how a coach wins a game it is
it's not giving the ball back to Ben at
the end of the half right knowing those
knowing those type of situations is what
makes Belichick and them awesome other
side of the ball I love when you write
this down in your notes who guarded who
on the first third down yeah and here's
who guarded who JC Jackson guarded juju
and we saw he made that play at the end
yeah JC's got it he's got he's got star
potential we you heard it here first
yeah Sims told you JC Jackson look out
for him Gilmore on Eli Rogers I burnt
except with that right eliminate see
live from the game did and then they
doubled Antonio Brown with Devon or
Jason McCarney gosh it's horrible as
I've known these guys since they wrote
down 30 I think that's Jason that's
Jason it is Devon yeah so Jason McCourty
and harm Harmon they double down Tonio
Brown what did that tell you that told
me that they
like the size and strength of JC Jackson
on Schuester which I get so JC's a big
kid he is a big kid
any place physical I think I want to say
he's 6 1 maybe and I'm gonna say like
205 oh we're in that range yep but then
the I think the other thing I'd look at
so then the they just wanted to cancel
out a be out of the thought 510 200 I
was wrong it's ok so he looks lot longer
than that
he was Marilyn so he's an ass and he's
strong as hell like any you saw he was
able to match up with juju on back
shoulder throws the throw at the end
like you mentioned where he got his arm
there in 14 benchpress oh did he really
yeah
120 inch broad jump 35 and a half inch
vert with a four for six yeah he's a he
was a top 50 pick in the draft but he
had off the field issues that's why he
ended up at Maryland because I believe
he was at Miami before that now they
like his matchup with juju they liked
his magic would do they eliminated Eli
Roger they eliminated Eli Broderick's
and really what they're trying to do
more than anything is just go Ben don't
even think about it over here we got two
on Antonio so you're gonna have to go
and when a quarterback sees double
coverage he pretty much moves on from it
right away he does he pretty much goes
okay I mean yes unless he feels like
it's some certain route where he goes
they might have a hard time with the
dance McDonald is bigger so yeah yeah
exactly right so that and then your
point to Gilmore like shutting Rogers
out yeah like that was that was not even
a contest now if they didn't double it
was Gilmore on a B and it was JC Jackson
on you think JC's super special I do I
really think he has a chance to be like
a big-time Island type corner wait where
did you look up his thing I looking at
roster right now it says he's 6 1 193
well I'm looking at him at the draft
when he measured in from oma Immokalee
Florida at 510 201 look at this could he
have grown three inches no I don't think
so
but look are they lying are the Patriots
lying and wouldn't know them to lie but
look it's six one one day I mean it's
dare he is I don't know it's crazy so
he's lost 10 pounds but he's grown three
inches that's incredible but yes I don't
know what I was going to say there but
keep steelers running game yeah I mean
how did it go
from not is it just because Dobbs was in
their last game well yeah and they they
can run the ball I hate to say if they
can't run outside well they can't run
the ball when Dobbs is in the game and
the defense goes well they're not gonna
throw the same stuff they would throw so
they can Jalen is good I told you that
for a long time ago he is the type of
style that fits what they do teaches
what he's like a good patient zone type
runner here's a lot of Le'Veon Bell
aspects let me attack the line of
scrimmage and kind of bounce and wait
until I see the hole and then as soon as
I see a hole I'll make a move he's got
incredible balance
he's got deceptive speed and he's get
deceptive power where he falls forward
two or three yards and you know that was
fascinating itself back to your gilmore
that second interception big been
through yeah to Harmon she and the crap
out of Roger it jammed him just ruined
the play to where Antonia was gonna be
open and get the catch but damn he's
gonna run into the wrong man this to
each other and of each other because he
could get off the line of scrimmage
Ben's first interception was so stupid
yeah you wrote bad decision no bad throw
dumb decision all special equals so
stupid so stupid it was like three
verticals right and the safety was he
threw the interception to the safety he
was over the inside vertical the other
two guys on the outside they're gone
see you later it's touchdown James
Washington is going to run by his guy
down the seam and there's no safety
really there chewed you in my player oh
that hurts you yeah hurt you another
fascinating I'm sorry I want to say this
to all the fantasy football players that
got eliminated this past week oh gosh no
welcome to freedom as soon as that game
ended and I knew that I didn't get
enough points from juju to win yeah the
weight lifted off my shoulders yeah
unbelievable yeah the whole day I'm
nervous it is so hard to watch a
football game when you have rooting
interest on one player because every
place em someone wears juju have a
generation every play like 30 yard pass
to a B and I'm gone
like I can't even watch the game yeah
cuz I'm sitting there going juicers open
and he's not open but it's bad right I'm
free yeah good I get to be a normal
football fan I hear yeah good that's
good that would drive me crazy I
couldn't do this so hard
so other thing to the second touchdown
pass to Antonio Brown right you said
they doubled a B and juju and juju and
did I read anything else that I wrote
not realistic assignment alignment
bypass exactly right so they played a to
safety alignment everybody I'll try to
do my best here but two safeties just in
your traditional spots June if you're
the quarterback everybody pretend
there's a quarterback behind the center
okay juju Smith Schuster is way out to
the left
okay there's juju yep and then they got
the next guy in is Antonio Brown okay
and they try to double both and then
slid four guys on the tight end and then
it's two other guys on the other side
okay and they are the safety that's to
the side of Antonio Brown and you juice
in the Shuster he's kind of lined up
over juju in the slot but as soon as the
ball gets snapped
JC Jackson who's guarding juju on the
outside he jumps outside right and that
safety immediately turns to juju so now
they haven't bracketed right Jade and
you're telling me the other safety had
to come from the other side of the field
to get to right because they're trying
to discourage been on the pre-snap read
to think there's another safe why don't
go over here throw it up right I would
make him throw to washy so all gay they
probably should have it I bet you that
would be something next time they play
them he'll go you know if they line up
in this formation we can't try to do
that because now McCourty was on Antonio
Brown as soon as the ball was step he
jumped outside right because he's going
to the safety the safety to come across
he had to come all the way across the
field exactly right left go and that's
why anybody around was open to another
they learn from that mistake but that's
why you saw him open for that touchdown
there they were actually trying to
double-team him Patriots
yeah Steelers yeah wrap it up with this
the AFC seating right now it's wide open
don't hate your answer the Patriots are
gonna have to play possibly a wild card
game yeah I can't remember the last time
they play the wild card it's 2009 Ray
Rice up the middle first play of the
game for like 70 yard touched
oh the Ravens just beat the crowd crowd
member that yeah there's a last time I
think they played a wild card game
pretty sure yeah pretty sure
and now Houston with their comeback win
over the Jets right they can end up
getting this to seat yeah and Houston is
a dangerous team at home definitely
definitely a dangerous Wow Patriots not
having a body yeah that is you're right
that's the story I mean it's just the
story is patronizing to neurone December
Patriots losing can't believe that's
happened since 2002 how does it say I
don't remember it 2002 so that was and
that was a year they missed right that
was the year after they won this right
so they missed that year they went ten
and six it was the only time that like
they had Brady play for a few games and
they like it wasn't the when he got hurt
from the Bernard Pollard year no no yeah
this was like he actually played and
they just didn't make yeah they didn't
make it they had to play I remember that
I can remember and now that you're
telling me the last game of the year
tell me if I'm right they're playing the
Miami Dolphins at home and they lost and
they know they won but they had to have
somebody else lose to get in and didn't
happen but I remember it's just funny I
remember at the time because I was
friends with some people in the NFL and
coaches and they were all even that year
we're like we're so glad New England
didn't get in cuz if New England got in
I just there's something about they were
already saying that that was something
about then yeah there's something about
them they're just seem unflappable Brady
and Belichick but yeah big weekend and
then we got chargers Baltimore this week
which I you're already all over
Baltimore in that game if you if you
want to know right now I think it's a
horrible matchup for the Kaiser okay
what do you think it should be so really
explain why like you were saying this in
the meeting today this could be a really
bad matchup for the church yeah it's a
it's a tough matchup for the Chargers
for one we know the Ravens defense is
really good so I do think they're gonna
give the Chargers offense a tough time
and I know the Chargers offense is
really good too I'm not trying to take
anything away I'm just saying I don't
think you mean expect the Chargers
offense to score 30 points this week I
think it'll be that type of game and you
know anybody that's out there what dial
up some film or turn on a game of the
Chargers look at their defensive line
and their linebackers it's I would I
would say it's the smallest group in
football and now you got to play the
Ravens what the line is the Chargers by
four and a half oh man the problem with
the
Ravens is every time I watch them like
Sunday it's like 14 play drives that end
in Field it's scary it's never gonna
make you feel comfortable bettin on the
rain ever no cuz I like a better as
underdogs it's it's a it's they're a
bludgeoning group but I do think they
can run the ball on the charges straight
downhill and put them in a big do you
want to go next Chargers chiefs or Colts
Cowboys um I guess let's go Chargers
Chiefs let's do that let's do more AFC
yeah Chargers Chiefs yep my favorite
moment of the game Tony Gonzalez is in
the booth and he says about an Antonio
Gates I mean he still play he must love
football I love when football players
that are retired and admit that they
didn't love football for the last few
years I thought it became too much right
then it's like so overwhelming for them
that's a weird aside for me but mahomes
you know has to carry the team again but
do you believe that Phillip Rivers
should be in the MVP race yes I do he
definitely should be in the MVP he's
number two for me over Brees I I don't
think that's yes I know you're being an
[ __ ] but I don't think it's crazy I
don't think it's crazy I think if you
looked at the quality of Phillip Rivers
throws this year and the degree of
difficulty that Travis Benjamin throw at
the end one fourth down was insane
I mean and he was like Troy Aikman was
just like Oh obsessing about it yeah he
should have because that's like that's
incredible feel and just timing and
knowing exactly what Wow does is even
before he like he threw it and it's like
he didn't even know Benjamin was gonna
go a little bit more vertically no Ralph
wasn't even the top of his route to
where he's gonna break it off yet no so
that just tells you years of practice
practice with him him you know how I
talk about body language or the
receivers him having a good idea
trusting that your receivers gonna go
and we'd said all week we're gonna break
this off at 12:00 [ __ ] you got
to break it off at 12:00 like you can't
break it off at eight in a big moment
and then I threw it to 12 and all of a
sudden you're getting complete you look
at me I was open oh we didn't talk about
it am I crazy that Mike Williams had the
game of his life and he should have
caught about five more balls and I why
do they throw it
Tyrell Williams so much yeah I don't
know he's not even like he's he was even
the third best receiver on the on the
field for them at the end of the game
and he was getting every ball
they don't play favorites like they're
not when I kept putting Tyrell on the
ISO spot yeah they they just I have no
direct answer for you there and I'll
break this down deep dive on Thursday
okay cuz I haven't watched this film yet
but they're not a team that I look at
and goes oh we're designing these plays
for this guy right they just feel like
they're good at nobody and exactly right
and then and Philip will go through the
reads and he'll get the ball to the guy
other than like third and four where
then then they might call some Keenan
Allen great change of direction routes
other than that they just call plays and
they go one of our guys is gonna get
open at Phillips in a find him shout out
to Anthony Lin yeah his clock management
at the end of the game left it to where
my homes didn't even get a suspect right
right going for two going for two which
I love right it's their weakness of
their team versus your strength do it
right here this was all of the fears you
had about the Chiefs yeah all the fears
I had about the cheese we saw I still do
they can win a Super Bowl I do too
I do too cuz my Holmes does things I've
never seen before they gotta have one
thing though to win the Super Why so
this is my big takeaway from that game
one thing and it goes back to our money
conversation right where's the strength
of your team where's the money on your
team spent who they missing they're
missing a guy that's being paid like
Odell Beckham jr. at the wide receiver
position okay that's an issue for them
yes Sammy Watkins has not played hardly
at all this hardly at all and that is
the game that emphasized it more we've
seen that was always the issue by the
way of yeah paying Sammy Watkins my
issue is not that he wasn't talent right
my issue is that I feel like he misses
eight games a year and dealing with the
foot injury since he got in the NFL and
then when he goes for like a hundred
forty yards to the he misses the next
night and he's dealing with a foot
injury again yeah I mean but think about
the Chiefs and the games that their
offense hasn't put up big numbers I'm
gonna talk about games a loss like the
Rams the Patriots but think about
Broncos right sure think about Arizona
these saw soft zones are you gonna run
the ball are you gonna throw it short on
us cuz you said she's had to run it 15
or more times they ran it 15 and they
were not
running it consistent I mean first of
all you have to do what you think is
gonna give you the best chance to win
the game and I just have a hard time
Andy Reid watched the film of the
charges he had a look and go damn their
nose tackles to 85 Damian Williams was
having success he was gash in them I
mean the last touchdown drive they had
they ran up the middle every time the
screens were open because the Chargers
were 25 yards down the field they were
going we're not gonna let Tyree kill and
Kelsey at 20 yards beat us all game long
so that was where my Sammy Watkins point
is Sammy Watkins they need him to beat
there's no Kareem hunt anymore which
they miss him too in the past game I
check down and him turning up and
getting 10 yards and jumping over humans
but think right but think about the
Chiefs they're made to outshoot you
that's how they've orchestrated their
team there's no real studs on the
defensive side of the ball yes and Tyree
kill needs somebody else to help him out
they give seven who Schmidt SATA to his
Ocho see exactly they keep sending him
deep him deep but there's nobody to come
underneath to really scare the defense
also what happens to we saw Tyreke he'll
come underneath and catch shallow
crosses early in the year because Sammy
Watkins was in and he could be the guy
that ran deep sometimes so you could
switch up their versatility a little bit
I do think that was brought out in big
lights that black the other night to go
yeah they might get away with us against
some teams but this is the Chargers who
have just enough to events to slow them
down and then they have an offense to
take advantage of your [ __ ] deep I feel
like the Chargers are better on the road
they do seem like the ultimate life
likens the way you like both la teams
when they're at home it magnifies how
they don't have a fan base right and
they feel bad yeah and then on the road
they're like we're underdogs yeah
there's like no energy in their home
state chargers down like 14 the Steven
Moore to the Steelers come back and win
yeah down that amount of points to the
Chiefs come back and win right pretty
unbelievable it is it's unbelievable
yeah there it's a weird weird thing
being an what's your level of confidence
of the Chargers now because I was
insulting them and I'd eat a lot of
chrome yeah you did after they eat that
huh I look at them and lump them
together you know again I think they're
dangerous could they be in the Super
Bowl certainly I look
then go join the party of the you know
AFC and the the flawed conference that's
what they should the American Florence
Oh the American flood come yeah I mean
that said they all have flaws to me
I mean Kansas City great offense [ __ ]
secondary Houston great defense but when
they play a good defense damn their
offense a pass game is just not good
enough to carry them in those type of
game it's where they struggled against
the Jets last week New England you know
I don't know they got I don't know what
the New England flaw is right now lack
of big plays in the pass game I don't
know what you want to say blow people
right lack of it maybe you know
Pittsburgh the one team I look at when
they don't [ __ ] it up I just go that's
their flaw it is a flaw is that a big
ben and Tomlin are prone to do make
things in dumb mistakes you're right
lack of discipline Chargers I worry
about what we'll see this week big
people big people against them pushing
their 190s putting up points exactly
right bolts success away from home field
yeah right that's what I mean so you go
through it right like the Ravens what
happens in that game where the Ravens
can't run the ball all the sudden are
they gonna be able to rely on the past
game to get them over I don't know yet
we haven't seen it but yeah I got to see
it to believe it
the Ravens flaw is that any team is in
it against them for 60 minutes yeah
pretty much you're right
they're never there never know they're
never gonna put teams out because
they're just not gonna score enough to
put you out all right so that that OH
Colts Cowboys yeah I saw something that
Prescott is completing this is before
the the Cowboys the Colts game yeah he
was completing 80 percent against zones
but it was almost entirely short base
passes yeah and before the Colts against
zone coverage no touchdowns and two
interceptions this is earlier yeah
the Colts Aten zone Amari Cooper was a
non-factor yeah I want to say that Zeek
honestly was a few like moves away from
breaking runs he was higher game right
but this offense yeah they had they had
three games at home they have our first
game on the road kind of like I
predicted I liked the Colts in this
matchup
but what did you see from that offense
that kind of gave him the first shutout
in 15 years blown opportunities now to
like the Cooper's own thing that's
that's real I mean just think about it
when you think about Cooper's big place
Thanksgiving
it was man-to-man against the Redskins
you know last week it was man-to-man I'm
when I read that it almost infuriated me
that the Eagle sat in man-to-man the
entire game yeah cuz dull it's
ridiculous right to even put them they
don't have the type of offense that's
schematically a creative enough that's
going to expose zone coverage all game
on it's just not good enough unless
they're running the ball so well that
okay now play actions and boots are
making things so wide open each team
play zone or are there more teams that
just play zone based defenses like what
do you mean like what are you saying
like does every can any team play zone
all the time if they wanted yeah yeah
definitely
they're definitely yeah like could Tampa
this week against Dallas sitting zone
the whole time they could yes yes they
definitely could they're just why not
yeah I mean that's to me you're playing
the Cowboys you just go the first thing
I would go is okay run game Zeke we got
to stop that next thing is let's just
not let Amari Cooper go deep on us you
know let's have a guy there by Gavin
Escobar right and what happens too is I
mean in man-to-man his route tree simple
it's a go route it's a post corner route
or it's a slant route and he outruns
everybody but when you play zones okay
there's a guy sitting there for the
slant route you know when you run the
post corner route there should be some
guy underneath that to discourage that
yeah you know when you run the go route
against zone the corners should be cover
three press bail on top of it not
letting him run by you
so I think that's the issue Cowboys same
thing as always though just like last
week had moments of dominating the game
and didn't capitalize on it Zeke getting
stopped on fourth down inside the five
when as we're talking about before just
kick the field goal right they got the
field goal blocked to start the game
amazing field position to the Colt right
where else they had another day they
didn't convert on to fourth and once
they had a fourth and two that they
converted on and threw a pass down the
middle of the Beasley that called back
for offensive holding
right how big of an issue is not having
Zack Martin it's it's an it's an issue I
think what even made it worse is once
sua filo got hurt yesterday then they
had to go one more down the line that
made it even worse because he got I
think he got poked in the eye or
something like that man
but yeah the Cowboys are the type of
team that once it became 17 nothing like
it's night night
they're not the type of team that's and
I'm like oh yeah Dax gonna drop back and
win a shootout comeback that's not the
way the way the Rams defense is built to
be up 14 the Cowboys offense is built to
be up 14 right exactly right exactly
right I mean the Cowboys had the ball
for 20 minutes out of the 30 minutes in
the first half Wow and it was 10 nothing
Colts so what do you think about the
Colts I should tell you is it just a
team overall the thing that I think is
the most surprising Hylton got off T Y
Hilden got off not as they shut down any
Braun they did shut down you're the Mack
ran for like a hundred and thirty
against that Dallas deep that's the
surprise of the day and that you know
those are things that I enjoy going back
and stuff scouting myself on is going
yeah like that's an area that I
overlooked and that matchup which part
just the fact that the Colts interior
three are just a bigger more physical
powerful three than the the woods and
Malik Collins combo for Dallas at D
tackle who are have decent size that are
a little more speed based and we're
gonna shoot the gap and create the
create you know chaos that way Colts are
like I like I always say every team has
their kryptonite every unit has their
kryptonite
Dallas bet there's yesterday hey man oh
damn wait our quickness there we're a
little quicker than them but not as
quick as we quicker as we usually are
and whoa they're really powerful like
whoa they're pulling guards in like
Marlon Mac's running up the middle for
ten yards before he gets touched those
type of things that's where I can order
this so I want to ask you this question
I'm not down on the Cowboys though I'm
not neither am i yeah it was a look it
was your first road game in a month it
was the first quarterback with the speed
receiver you've played in a month right
it was this
for it was the first good offensive line
you face in a month hmm
you didn't have Zack Martin and you came
out there and you got beaten by the zone
and you had a few opportunities to score
and you messed it up exactly right
they didn't get beaten like that but now
he gets shut up I know the score looks
like they got beaten but it really is
not
you know conducive to look more like a
21-10 or yeah something like that right
are we rooting for the Ravens to get the
six or the whole save this thing it's
one of the two not rooting for the
Titans absolutely get the hell out of ya
and nowhere are we rooting for the
Dolphins no I just want the Dolphins to
get one more win so that I hit my over
for the season okay I got that at plus
140 and they got to play the Patriots
and the bills and the bills all my
money's on the bills and what's
incredible Dan they cook the milk to
buffle I took the bill under hey I'll
have to play the Patriots it's the bills
and who's the other game I'll find it
you want me to get it first I'll beat
you you can't be I messed up a buffalo
in Jacksonville damn they're not out of
the woods yet okay but what it could
come down to if the Dolphins lose and
let's say the bills loose yeah at that
last game of the year if the Dolphins
win I hit my dolphins over my bills
under but if the bills win I lose both
oh man that'll be cool oh that's exactly
what I hope for but but I'm with you
Colts or Ravens yeah
coats or Ravens the Colts play the
Giants and at the Titans ya can win both
yeah that Titans game though is gonna be
unbelievable yeah
the Ravens play at the Chargers which is
very lose abou it is and then home
against the Browns very usable right are
we rooting for the Colts of the Ravens
what's the best six in the AFC I'm gonna
think about hold on let me just look at
the standings let's say that it stays to
how it is right now with the Houston
getting the two seat right that would
mean that New England that this team
goes to New England would we rather the
Ravens or the Colts go to New England
the Ravens me too yeah I want to see the
Ravens in as much as they because the
Rays just run all over the right that
would be that would be the New England
page they would not want to see the
Ravens coming
town because the you know again the
Patriots want to run the ball to this is
not the old Patriots they still want to
go I formation and do they did that
yesterday just every time they broke a
big run somebody I call for whole the
Patriots fall to the for would they
rather be the three and play the Ravens
or the four and play the charger roof
man
that's a good question they match up
better with the players on the field for
the Chargers in my hate and my money for
my money so we're rooting for the Ravens
to get the six yeah we are I think
they're one of the best six teams and I
always root for one of the six best and
I think the six best are in right now
mmm that's at least my thought Colts
will not be they will be fun yes there's
no doubt they're just not getting a home
de-seed and they're just dangerous at
home yep
alright so you gave me your weaknesses
and all that stuff did you hear shall
Aerith on the broadcast say that Tampa
Bay was out Baltimore in Baltimore I did
not hear it but of course saw the text
and what did you think yeah I think he's
listening he's think he's Lizette ik is
that a phrase what's up stink no I mean
if it is I coined it I mean that I need
the money
what's up mister I mean come with me let
me hear it
it goes throughout bowl Turing Baltimore
in Baltimore okay the last part mark
sheriff callie's butcher his last name
Schley right yeah siren Clara
yeah hey stinkers awesome player hope
he's listen to the body um morty crown
us yeah Baker may feel yeah I I went
back and I didn't get to watch that game
life and I got to rewatch it some of his
throws they're fun throw it up Rashad
Perryman what like I can't even believe
he threw it he's um
reorganizing guys at the end of the game
to get that throw to Callaway right and
then I read Peter Kings article the way
he manipulated the defense there and
kind of read it and kind of had three
different plays he went through is that
what he said it's gonna be huh excuse me
gonna be a run right did a quick huddle
so that the other team couldn't do a
substitution right went out there move
the running back to the other side as
soon as he'd do that he saw the
linebacker shift which then he knew was
man a man right and he saw the safety
Simmons on Callaway went that's that's
it
yeah and that's what he went with he's
come on chance
the Browns make Freddy kitchens their
head coach like Freddy kitchens has to
stay are you putting Greg well I am NOT
hiring Greg Williams as my head coach
I'm not either and look what what he's
done with them I do not care Greg
Williams is not the guy to get the best
out of Baker Mayfield he's not know do
you keep I mean I wouldn't be sure Greg
Williams altogether I mean you know if
they brought the right head coach in
there Greg Williams might be like okay
I'll go to the descends the coordinator
I'll do know it depends on he wore a
suit to his head coach interim process
like he wants to be the head guy
apparently he does yes he has four wins
yeah in like six games yeah and Hugh
Jackson didn't have four wins in two
seasons no and it's amazing how much his
defense has improved since he's taken
over and I want to give some credit to
his son because it sounds like his son
has taken over a lot of the duties he
had well I look at you and your dad I
look at me and my dad I think you're a
more refined version myself I am not
reach
Bruce you're better I don't know yeah I
mean you don't go you're not in the
elevator and go I got the Wi-Fi huh
this is Bruce Saturday night my brother
got engaged to his his girlfriend is now
fiance Jordan Jason congratulations yeah
we pull up to valet and the guy goes
here's how this is gonna work you're
gonna get a text message when it gets to
you you're gonna click a button and
that's what we're gonna bring the car
around so you're telling me that I'm
gonna click a button and then it's gonna
come around well there's another button
I just I don't get it so like I'm gonna
hit a button five minutes Bruce I love
you you're the man that's great you know
man but he's also the kind of guy that
the thing that I appreciate about him is
he's the ultimate ballbuster yeah the
ultimate bulb yes sir you know he comes
out he comes out of my brother's
apartment and there's people like
waiting for the door to be opened and my
dad's gone I can't let you in I'm sorry
you don't know anybody in here no you
gotta leave get the hell out of here but
what kind of coached like here we were
looking for a coach for Rogers what kind
of a coach for this up-and-coming Browns
team that is gonna be the job of the
offseason it it I mean it is you wanna
you know the big thing I just keep
looking about since he took over is
kitchens I'm talking about Freddy
kitchens is again going back to like
playing To Your Strengths again their
money is on their offensive line and
they weren't running the ball when Haley
and everybody else to you we're calling
the plays now they've gone oh we got a
high second-round pick and all these
good old linemen let's run the ball and
then make life easy on our great
throwing quarterback who when he sees
one on one can hit the bull's eye
ninety-nine out of a hundred times when
he has to make that throw I think that's
if I could just put it in simplest form
sir what they've done for Baker Mayfield
it's that right there I don't care that
like his stats are 18 for 31 for 188
it's a little bit like Aaron Rodgers the
throws he does make they're like they're
game changing plays right the touchdown
pass the Perriman to start their their
plays we're yeah he didn't throw this
like 20-yard pass
Queen the 30s he when he sees that he
strikes four touchdowns or puts them
inside the redzone whatever it may be
it's when the throws occur that changed
the game that I think is so impressive
by maker Baker Mayfield and he's just
got a he's a savant he's a natural to
position and he's an unreal thrower the
football who do they get is their coach
yeah I don't know well we'll get into
this I better start really thinking
about this as we get closer to d-day at
the end of the season I have two great
moments and gambling that happened one
that was against me and one that was for
me I'm watching the game on my phone and
I see that that the Jets are winning and
here comes DeAndre Hopkins with the
touchdown Texans have to win by six they
go up four and I turn it off I go that's
the game but at least I got the cover
I'm at the restaurant I go to take a
piss and I go let me just see how it
finished how the hell did the Texans get
another field goal right awful moment in
gambling when you close your phone you
go at least I got the cover and you
realize that the Jets went for it for
them whatever at their own thing you out
and led to a Texans field goal I'd do a
Texas deal when they couldn't kneel the
clock to get it over and he had a it was
an awful moment in Game one
yeah he had to have a gutsy decision to
go for you know I got a kick the field
all here and go up by seven a great
moment in gamble yeah Chicago Green Bay
Oh Green Bay down ten they're inside the
10 yard line
and Joe Philbin decides well we need two
possessions anyway let's kick the field
goal right and go for the onside kick
right never in my life did I applaud Joe
Philbin so loudly yes that is a Chicago
cover the buyers but remember remember I
looked at you afterwards and said
Chicago or Jacksonville and you said
Chicago they're gonna beat him but even
then it wasn't even it was too close
yeah it was Minnesota Miami though they
had the Freddy kitchens effect new OC
Dalvin cook was everywhere
ran the ball right out the middle my
keys all of a sudden look dangerous all
of a sudden well I mean if they can do
that it's like it's a it's almost like
going back you know to what we were just
saying about the Eagles a little bit ago
okay like I'm gonna remind
everybody here we go 2017 here's the
rushing stats oh there's the Vikings 7th
and football with a hundred and twenty
two yards per game last year
this year what are they down in the
upper 20s
somewhere in that they are 32nd
they're the worst running team info oh
I'm wrong I'm on sixteen sorry what
they're on my dime 2016 Oh their 29th
okay something is that much better no
but what I saw a dolphin cook was what
we've been looking for all year it's the
most special guy in there offense with
the ball in his hands so yeah I mean
they're gonna be a pain in the butt if
they can run the ball and do that and
then create the one-on-one matchups
because then you have to worry about
stopping the run yeah they could be
dangerous cuz we know their defense is
damn good
props to our favorite coach of the NFL
Kyle Shanahan gets the win over Seattle
he cracked the code again few of those
throws to the tight ends wide open
Selleck wide open Kittel wide open wide
open he found other ways to do Seattle
beaters on that like Selleck wide open
touchdown have you get a chance and I go
back and look how we did it you know he
I don't even want to get too deep into
it I just say that either way he had
Selleck to the right right yes okay and
he had the back behind the quarterback
and then they had the fake reverse speed
sweep coming with it so what he did is
I'm guaranteeing he realized that that
you're gonna pull up the play itself
yeah yeah so I the rules are gonna
change for the Seattle defense where
they want this corner to be pressed
Brett cover three bills right but since
motion the motion comes and then the
safety so now he has to switch roles
with the linebacker go by Becker as
knowing well yeah he has no idea he's
not used to it and he's supposed to be
carrying him up to seam now because they
switched roles so so Kyle saw one play
two years ago in which motion came and
it changed the rules and he said I'm
gonna attack that he goes I don't think
this guy knows his rule I'm not that
question to that yes right does he know
he really has one chance to make that
work or do you attack that as long as I
think as often as you can
yeah no what happens more times or not
is you don't waste those plays right
you're not just gonna call that play and
go well I hope
you don't do it the first place no yeah
I hope they line up in the defense I
think they're gonna line up in all game
you run those formations to go okay
they're lining up the way I thought so
you're even you're even gonna do the
exact formation once or twice early in
the game and maybe give it to that Jets
exactly or running or whatever right
something just to go let me see if
they're playing it the way I expect to
or they double call play in the huddle
and they go okay we're gonna run this
run play if they're in this defense but
if they're in that defense we just saw
in the touchdown there yeah we're I'm
gonna check to this pass play because we
got the look we want and we're gonna run
it are the players nervous when you have
a beater and you've been sitting on it
all week and it's time to unleash it oh
no they're like foaming at the mouth
excited yeah
can the defense tell ya like they can
start to tell as the game goes like we
saw a jam fighting on the sidelines last
year remember against San Francisco they
could tell like what the you're supposed
to do this I'm supposed to do that you
did this but I met have a line of
scrimmage a smile they're like oh [ __ ]
no the oh no no the offense is that's my
on the offense it's like extra serious
underlying saying it's like they're yeah
they're like they're extra serious and
trying not to give any tells like you
know like we're gonna run over here and
they're running backs like looking over
to the left the whole time you know like
Kelly keeps looking over there but I
mean the Carolina plays like oh you
watch Phil they don't I watch film too
Yeah right
I had to feel so good yeah I thought
Nick Mullens played really well he did
he did he's had a lot of really good
moment I he's a solid backup in yes no
doubt I think I think yourself an
eight-year career yes and I think Josh
Jackson just entered himself out of the
AAA felon into the end - Johnson yeah
yeah we'll see first NFL start her first
victory I worse oh my gosh how did and
you know I know it's really crumbling
yeah when I asked after the game Jalen
Ramsey said I don't know about diamond
Ron I only know about myself when asked
after the game Leonard fournette said
nah not running the ball was part of the
game plan Doug Marrone I don't know
about my job here rumors last week Tom
Coughlin's gonna come down from the from
the booth right I mean he's gonna do the
Pat Reilly
that know what that Pat Riley didn't do
yeah yeah no I know this Tom Coughlin's
coming down is not gonna make that team
better no definitely not they in fact
it's only gonna embolden their dumb
decision making from before their um
yeah they got some evaluating to do this
offseason self scout bro self scout but
you know again I'm not gonna really
argue the results on the offensive side
of the ball when you have 70 and 71 as
your quarterback I want to wrap up
speaking of quarterbacks fading always
wrap up the story of the Giants came out
before the game they're gonna go into
2019 with Eli Shermer believes he still
got some left in the tank because the
owner told me I have to say that so I'm
going to say that but halfway through
the game I'm sitting there going can you
guys please have that reevaluate you
can't do anything when they do something
and he throws an interception that a
rookie would throw and then throws the
bumblers tumbler and it backed up too so
now that I take points off the board for
his own team then the various defense
makes a stop after Joe's the
interception they make the stop they
punt it yeah and he fumbles it and gives
them another touchdown and make it 14
nothing finally thank you to the Giants
yeah they're made by Eli next year
thank you to Washington for being an
absolute cluster of a mess and hurting
your draft pick thank you to the Cowboys
for constantly not advancing your
offense the fact that the Eagles even
have a chance this year is insane yeah
next year I'm ready to make a return I'm
ready the NFC East is run by a bunch of
joke it'sit'sit's I don't know what to
say about mystical Jerry overcome
Stadium Giants and dance night last week
is like you know Peyton broke down Matt
Stafford's play write about staring down
receivers you know just I don't know it
just bothers me like I know Peyton's the
man he's one of the three greatest
quarterbacks all-time but there he is
gonna break down Stafford's game who's
been carrying his team for the last nine
years and now he's having a rough year
and he's
tell him to stop looking at receivers
and then yet he's gonna do his brother's
game against the 49ers of all teams a
few weeks ago and say look and look how
he throws this four yard check down to
bar claim he made a big deal about that
that day yeah that was a big play it was
a great throw all four yards of it like
I just have issues with that that's like
that's political [ __ ] in the NFL
that I'm not gonna back down I don't
care if I know you would be more than
Peyton so it justice to me bothered me
there I couldn't I couldn't help that
yeah it's annoying it's annoying yeah
you excited to listen to booger and
Witten doing I'm excited for that game
today man I don't think there's anything
else other than Josh Rosen pooping his
pants no and I mean I don't know much
about that game I saw Josh Allen make
some awesome right all the other things
I want Detroit screwed that game up
though oh yeah with the missed field
goals extra point
yeah what else happened there was
another turnover I feel like that I'm
missing
Robert Foster's a legit receiver in this
league yeah I Adam Thielen yeah he's
legitimately a [ __ ] talker I was
watching that game he was John with all
of the Miami Dolphin right Adam Phelan
is a Trojan horse people think Adam
feelings happy to be there cuz he went
to like Minnetonka Minnesota and he's
white and he's a receiver let me just
tie some Adam feelings out here cursing
out Belichick and doesn't give a crap
about anybody I love it I do too he's
got an edge about him I'm just trying to
think of all the other stuff that I
thought good pick by Eric Harris your
safety for Oakland yes I did see that
Joe Mixon looked unbelievable again yeah
yeah let's see I'm just trying to think
there's any other hand written down was
Frank Clark had a quote they put up that
said this is my - yeah it's it's my
defense not Richard Sherman vitamins do
you ever see the movie hook nope what I
never saw it Frank Clark is Rufio mmm
Frank Clark was like they're my Lost
Boys and in your heart like they're
never a girl I like that he said that
that I saw him say that lassie yeah
defense this guy you can't let Richard
Sherman do that well the same thing with
Seattle that we've we've said like
Seattle has to dominate and they have to
dot their run game is the dump
they don't that's what's crazy yeah I
guess they had Doug Baldwin played a
great game
he did but did they you know okay I'm
just trying yeah they dominated better
than I thought they yeah how many good
yeah I mean Carson had won 119 that's
what I'm saying he did yeah they did a
lot of good it was just they let up a
few big place to San Francisco yeah and
there we've talked about that missed an
extra point their defense is not the
same on the road they're another team I
mean you look at Carolina a few weeks
ago on the road they got torched I know
they won the game but they got tore I
don't know if you've noticed but my
betting habits yeah all I care about is
where is the game and what happened last
game because you guys are an emotional
mess and if you just had a big win and
you go on the road you're gonna get your
ass kicked you are yeah that's why I
like the Panthers tonight I like the
Panthers I do all right you know why
let's you want to see how I do a game
yeah this is how I do a game Sims and
then we got to get the hell out of here
because we're we're having a long
podcast Panthers let's look at them
Panthers on the road right one-in-six
right at home five and one five losses
in a row yeah emotional angry really
feeling it gonna come out right New
Orleans last game at Tampa I get the win
at this is their third road game in a
row there's six and one on the road for
sure I don't know man yeah I hear you
there's a lot of things there to be
worried about Minnesota on the road not
a great game escaped Baltimore on the
road kind of got owned a little bit
right I don't know I I think that
Carolina and Cam Newton are gonna have
one of their best performances of the
year I hope so
I'm rooting for him tonight just to make
things interesting in the NFC it's
alright alright so you're gonna go watch
some film yep and I'm gonna go come up
with weird conspiracy theory stop giving
our viewers the plague and coughing into
the mic oh they could hear it yeah if
you got sick write a note that Adam got
you sick and I will I will sign it via
social media
four sentence peace out on me Hendrick
says good evening
and cam Hayward appreciate you yeah the
lef koe man real holla holla holla at
you later this week hallo